rhodes michael paalan michael chorost
and james kaulder they gathered recently
at the Commonwealth Club of California
for this hour-long talk good evening I'm
David Ewing Duncan I'm a science writer
author and freelance correspondent for
ABC Nightline and I want to welcome you
all to tonight's meet of a meeting of in
forum a division of the Commonwealth
Club buy-in for people in their 20s and
30s with a mission to inspire debate
around civic issues tonight's event is
co-sponsored by lik quake San
Francisco's annual literary festival and
the club's good lit program
now our topic tonight is about the S
word that's science a word that excites
some people but puts well a lot of other
people to sleep in fact we had to put
another s word into our title sex so you
get many of you here and those of you
who might also be wondering if our topic
should be in the form of a question is
science sexy and I think we're all here
to argue
the case for the affirmative on that
question and we'll let you all decide
later if that's the case to describe
we're planning to describe what's going
on in cutting-edge science among us we
write about re-engineering humans and
sundry other creatures building bombs it
can flash-fry us in an instant and about
trying to understand the planet as it
was created by nature lots of other
things too this is a very eclectic and
accomplished panel here as you all know
we probe the ancient question will
science save us or destroy us we want to
talk about also what inspires us and how
we do our best to share our inspiration
and also where science intersects with
society and politics particularly at a
time when science is under attack in
some quarters and we have a fabulous
panel tonight and to my left here is
Richard Rhodes the author of more than
20 books including novels and works of
history journalism and letters he
making of the atomic bomb when a
Pulitzer Prize for general nonfiction
James Calder has written three novels
and the bill Damon's series including
the most recent in a family way his
books explore what it feels like to be
human in a rapidly developing posthuman
future michael chorost is author of
rebuild how becoming part computer made
me more human and it's going to be very
interesting here in 2001 he had a
computer implant permanently installed
in his brain
to regain severe hearing loss and then
Michael Pollan on the far left there is
the author of three books the botany of
desire second nature in a place of my
own
he teaches journalism at UC Berkeley and
contributes to the New York Times
Magazine among many other publications
now I want to go directly here to the
inspiration question because we are here
in a sense to persuade you to I think
we've got some science nerds in the
audience I think we've got some people
who are not and we're going to try to
hear in a brief period of time maybe
bring you all together a little bit here
on on what gets us off anyway about
writing about science and let's go right
to that question and by the way I'm
going to put the panel's feet to the
fire here a little bit I I don't want
platitudes about I was looking at a
daisy one day and decided to write about
science so I want you guys to give me
some good answers about why you're
passionate about this subject and let's
start with Richard you've written
literally hundreds of thousands of words
about a topic that dominated the 20th
century and hopefully maybe won't
dominate as much this century that's yet
to tell on the bomb why why would you
write about this and the other question
that's related is why science in a book
that could have started in 1942 why
begin a book with the discovery of the
electron in 1898 I believe you know when
I started thinking about writing a book
about the development of nuclear weapons
I was about 42 years old it was 1979 the
arms race had been ongoing and was
accelerating during the Reagan era and I
they did wonder if we were all going to
blow ourselves up it seemed to me that a
species is clever and adaptive his ours
surely had some other intention besides
its own destruction even though it had
significantly invented the means to do
that for the first time in the 20th
century I should say discovered the
means to do that so for me there was an
interesting conjunction of that time in
midlife in the seasons of a man's life
where you start thinking about your own
mortality and the fact that it looked to
me at that time as if we were all
risking our mortality in a very dramatic
way when an arms race that seemed to
have no end
Gorbachev hadn't arrived on the scene
yet that was the conjunction for me
personally to write about this subject
but because it seemed to me that if I
went back to the beginning maybe there
had been other paths that we might have
taken and that maybe by going back and
looking very carefully at the beginning
I might find those and I think I did I
think there were alternatives and still
are to the path that we've stayed on all
these years but let me just quickly add
something to that the question of why
puts so much science in a book that was
about the development of nuclear weapons
comes to the point of something that
people are still I think uncertain and
confused about about the discovery of
how to release nuclear energy and that
is was it something that Oppenheimer and
his crew or Verner Heisenberg and his
crew or whoever could have said no let's
not do this if we don't do it who will
ever know it wasn't in other words as
it's often presented a Faustian bargain
and I think when you look at the science
and this is one very good reason to look
at the history of science you realize
that it was inevitable that if nuclear
fission had not been discovered in Nazi
Germany in December of 1938 it would
have been discovered somewhere else
within a week or two it was one of the
scientists told me a discovery that was
overripe so there was an inevitability
about the discovery that made it
something that
was not really anybody's choice once she
knew such a thing was possible you had
to start thinking about how you could
defend yourself against it and as I've
come to formulated in and talking about
dr. atomic recently opposite a new opera
Oppenheimer and his crew yet the new
opera in San Francisco excuse me
Oppenheimer and his crew were not going
about the business of inventing a new
weapon of mass destruction that was not
their purpose their purpose was to
develop something that might protect the
Allied nations against a weapon of mass
destruction in the hands of Nazi Germany
that's a very important distinction and
it speaks again to the universality of
the discovery and therefore of its
impact on the world so we had an
inevitability just like today you might
have stem cells or we'll get to
reengineering humans here in a minute I
mean science at a certain level just
becomes inevitable and I mean it was a
particular impetus to drive it then I
like the way the Niels Bohr phrased this
discovery and I think it applies for all
science this wasn't the discovery just
of how to release nuclear energy it was
a new knowledge of the natural world and
when you have a new knowledge of the
natural world there's really not very
much you can do except decide how you're
going to relate to it you can't really
wave it away you can't really say well
no evolution is just a theory you're
going to have to deal with the fact that
evolution is a model for all sorts of
valid and well-supported evidence and
information but I suppose one way to
wave it away is to say that well it's
all so complicated there must have been
an intelligent designer my example for
this intelligent designer is the male
prostate case closed I told you to get
sciences sexy here
okay James kaulder writes the bill Damon
mysteries as I mentioned earlier he's a
well actually we have a couple of
novelists on the panel Richard also
writes novels but James does that
exclusively and he writes a little bit
about the underbelly of science and it's
it's basically a science where science
meets dashiell hammett and it's a sort
of noir science books his are fabulous
if you haven't read them by the way but
James what inspired you to not only
write about science but also in this in
this venue that you've chosen well I
gave it in my case it is the sex I'm no
actually I mean what I'm particularly
interested in and what in a family way
is about is reproductive engineering and
we you and I have talked about how we we
tend to use in our work ancient frames
or myths like the Prometheus or the
Faust myth to try and understand the the
momentous changes that are looming and
in bioengineering and genetic
engineering and and which have this
sense of inevitability and I think in
our case we're trying to look forward
you know and and think in advance about
that I've been doing some research on on
the origin the foul story and came
across a retelling of it by the poet DJ
Enright in which he has Mephisto say to
Faust every god has its day what would
you like to do with yours and to me
that's the question and in a nutshell is
we're gaining the power of creation and
what are we going to do with it and
thinking about what why personally I've
found this so compelling for many years
now I I don't know I wonder if it has to
do with being raised Catholic and and
having a sense of being created for a
certain purpose which you better not
stray from and you know trying to find
my own way out of that and you know I
mean now I think we tend to think more
of that nature created us or our parents
created us but
how is it gonna feel when you know
someone becomes consciousness that
technology created you and so that's
yeah in a family way is is about it's a
family drama it's about parents and
children and reproductive engineering
and not necessarily cloning which is
might be the in the end the least
interesting aspect of it although
cloning does raise the specter of the
egomaniacal parent wanting to create a
copy of himself but if you think about
that I mean there have always you know
for eons been parents who want to create
children in their own image and so what
I'm interested in is when these age-old
impulses collide with and are magnified
by the new technologies and I'm not by
any means an opponent of them I mean I
I'm fascinated by the research that's
happening but I think you know what what
I want to try and get people thinking
about is you know who controls them and
you know what will it feel like to be a
human being and the supposedly posthuman
future and human nature being human
nature you know what's going to happen
as it gains more and more godlike powers
okay so a little bit of the dark
underbelly which we'll talk about a
little bit more so we have actually here
some man who describes himself as a are
you a part cyborg or an actual cyber
cyborgs are always part there are always
hybrids there's no such thing as a true
cyborg
yes as well a small percentage of you is
is electronic Michael has if you I'm not
sure if you can see it but on the side
of his head there is a device that's
been implanted oops he just took it off
now he can't hear us
I guess one definition of a cyborg I
would wouldn't mind being is I can take
it off I think your hack when you can't
take it off maybe as when you cross a
line but Michael maybe will tell you his
story briefly here but it's quite
extraordinary and there are actually
several tens of thousands of
people walking around now with with
implants of some sort brain implants
about a hundred thousand people for
various conditions in this case for
hearing but he has the unique role on
the panel here of actually being an
object of science or a result of science
as well as being a writer who's written
about it
so Michael I mean I don't think I need
to even ask you what inspired you
obviously you here but maybe you can
tell us you know why you chose writing
and to express what you went through
well the inspiration for my book was
simple
I went deaf suddenly unexpectedly I
might add I was on the business trip
I just gotten off of an airplane I
thought my hearing aid batteries were
family
it wasn't he was my ears that were
failing my left ear specifically and I
was already a person with a long history
of hearing loss I was familiar with
cochlear implants I never imagined that
I would have to get one this will tell
you that I'm a writer on the flight home
which was precipitate I thought to
myself you know I might be able to get a
book out of this and they did and
literally wrote my way through the
experience
I wrote a memoir while I was going
through the experience that I was
memorizing and that is very unique way
to go through an experience because it
may be in a sense both subject and
object in a dual sense or is the subject
of medical technology incentives
subjectively experienced it and the
object in the sense that I was being
worked on rebuilt recreated so the [ __ ]
is that reflection on that process of
being rebuilt and rebuilding oneself and
I literally wrote my way through that
experience can you explain to us just
briefly what a cochlear implant is it's
quite extraordinary really indeed a
cochlear implant is essentially an
electronic replacement of an ear I
showed you the processor which looks
like a hearing aid it's not a hearing
aid it's a computer the round disc this
thing by the way I've just rendered
myself deaf by Tina's off I can't hear
my own voice now
so I trust and I'm still wonderful but
this disc here is actually a radio
transmitter in his beaming down and
through my skin to an implant in my
skull that has electrodes that penetrate
into my cochlea about inch and a half
deep in my skull in fact when I look at
the x-rays my head from the front you
can see the electrode array wrapped
around my cochlea right where the iris
of my eye is that's two things first I
look exactly like the Terminator and
second it shows you had deeply the
electrodes penetrate inside my skull I
was startled when I saw those x-rays I
hadn't realized the surgeon went that
deep it is a very invasive operation and
a very profound experience to go through
david said that it was a small part of
my body and that's true in terms of
weight a cochlear implant weighs several
ounces at the most but it completely
changes the way I experience my world so
in that sense it is a very large part of
my perceptual experience even thought it
is tiny its impact on me is enormous
because when I was activated with in
advance I had to learn how to hear all
over again everything sound like
gibberish the day that I was activated
because my company was being stimulated
in a totally different way so I wanted
to write about that excitement and the
terror of that process of learning how
to learn in a new kind of body I mean
this is literally a processor that takes
what I'm saying right here it translates
it into the electrical signals that
defeat into the the nerve essentially
that then is translated by his brain and
it is quite extraordinary
I like the terminology of being
activated you were not - the Terminator
yet anyway to the far left there as
Michael Pollan and everyone on the panel
here writes beautifully but Michaels
prose to me anyway I'm sure most of you
or many of you have read his book botany
a desire of not his other books it reads
to me like like poetry at times and I
just think it was such an extraordinary
idea
to take a basic fact of science which is
that we all interrelate as species we
don't think about this as humans you
know we've sort of grown up over the
centuries thinking we you know we're in
charge and what we say goes but in fact
there's a delicate dance going on all
the time among different species and
Michael's a gardener and he used his
love of gardening and and developed us
this idea of different plants and how
they interact with us and Michael what I
mean this this as a writer I stand
somewhat in all of this I stand in
complete awe because you took an idea
which no one should have really been
able to turn into a book and you did it
how did you do it I'm not sure I know
you know for me there there was sex
involved in this whole process but it
was I'm afraid it was just plant sex and
the inspiration for that book and
actually inspiration for a lot of things
I've written have come to me in the
garden doing very ordinary things and
one of the things I've always liked
about gardening is it leaves a lot of
mental space free it's not that
intellectually demanding weeding or
picking things and you know I tell the
story and then introduction of the book
but it was watching a bumblebee visiting
an apple tree that was in bloom at a
time when I was planting potatoes and
asking myself one of those you know kind
of stupid but also kind of profound
questions and they're often the same
which is what did I have in common with
that d and you know it was being
manipulated it thought it was in charge
it was deciding what blooms to go to it
thought it thought it was getting the
better of the apple tree getting off
with the the nectar but in fact it was
being cleverly manipulated to pick up
some pollen and move it around and it
had been manipulated to visit that
particular blossom and not another
a pattern of color and scent and
arrangement of petals and I realized
well that's true of me too with these
potatoes the potato in some sense is
manipulating me it's evolved to appeal
to my desires and this is not an
original idea this is a this is a fact
of evolution of coevolution but I asked
myself at that point wouldn't it be
interesting to look at our relationships
to domesticated creatures and I wasn't
sure at the time if I would just do
plants or do animals as well cuz it
applies equally well to domesticated
animals and try to see things from their
point of view we automatically think of
ourselves as subjects in nature acting
on a world of objects but of course now
for the for the various parasites in our
gut and for the for our pets and for the
things we eat we are objects as well so
it was a matter of perspective
and that's kind of a for me that was an
arresting discovery that you could write
a book out of you know not so much out
of information although there's tons of
information and reporting in the book
but but that a perspective was as good
as information in terms of giving you a
way into the world so it was just a door
for me inspiration is just finding that
kind of door now that sounds also I
should also say and none of us have
mentioned this but sometimes inspiration
is a matter of necessity sometimes
inspiration is a matter of an editor
whispering the right word and you hear
at the right time and these things don't
all you know come full-blown out of our
heads sometimes people are interested in
having you write about something for
their own reasons and and and the
passion comes as a byproduct of the work
very often I actually don't start
projects with a lot of passion I start
them with some curiosity a question in
my mind a little cognitive dissonance
about something why is this that way and
not this way or why do I feel this way
what is this why am i confused about
this and then in the process of delving
into that if it's the right subject
luckily it isn't always sometimes you
you know you have a dry hole
then the passion begins that's a pretty
awful thing when you start a book which
is a two-year project at least sometimes
much longer and about halfway through
you you lose that thread that's
definitely I want to shift here slightly
and talk about something that we've
we've all touched on but I want to read
a quote from Robert Oppenheimer from the
making the atomic bomb dick Rhodes book
taken as a story of human achievement
and human blindness discoveries in the
sciences are among the great epics and
we've been using the word sexy but the
word epic could also be used and I won't
join the two together because we've done
enough of that already but the idea of
this quote from Oppenheimer is
achievement and blindness and it's
something I've long been fascinated with
which is the idea of science and
technology being a double-edged sword
you know we we get great things out of
it but they're always great dangers and
even invention of fire or the discovery
of fire if you think about it there were
probably anti fire people it's gonna
burn us down it's gonna you know so this
has long been with us it's long been a
danger and I wanted to ask the panel and
anyone can jump in here you lean towards
hope that science will bring us hope and
will solve our problems or do you lean
against fear that you know we should be
careful I kind of know which way you'll
go but I'll talk about hopes and fears
let me just throw in another remark by
another scientist that I've always liked
it I think parallels Oppenheimer's
remark this this particular scientist
said the pace of scientific discovery is
slow because it's mediated by human
intelligence and I think Neil's board
like to knock along all that for long
that's true
Niels Bohr like to say that science
isn't about getting power over nature
since after all we're a part of nature
but rather it's about the gradual
removal of prejudices and by prejudices
he meant beliefs that are not supported
by evidence thus Galileo and
the question of what the the Sun going
around the earth or vice versa us and
evolution to come back to that subject
and really thus the discovery of not a
release ticular energy because wars were
based on the idea that you could
accumulate more explosives than the
other guy and therefore prevail and
turns out that's not true everything in
the universe can be made into energy if
you know how to arrange it properly so
but to the question of how I don't see
anything else that can save us accept
science it's the only human discipline
that requires evidential support and
adjusts itself accordingly when the
evidence isn't there with all of the
with all of the fraud with all of the
confusion with all of the excursions
into horrors like eugenics nevertheless
science does actually progress in the
sense that we learn more about the world
from year to year and in addition to
that and this is a more spiritual reason
for hope I think out of this wonderful
rich discipline it's inexhaustible the
world is fractal it's equally
complicated at every level you just can
go down and down and down into the
universe or up and out and out into the
universe and it's equally complicated
anyone who follows astronomy as I try to
do and have tried to do over the years
must be as amazed as I am at how what
was once simply points of light in a
firmament we astronomers keep finding
new ways to tease more information out
of this this seemingly tiny bit of light
it's fascinating to me how that happens
and of course it's made a world that is
infinitely richer and more various than
we ever imagined before so it's always
been a source of hope for me and in
particular in my case and the things I
write about hope for finding a way to
alleviate or to control or to eliminate
human violence because in a way most of
my books have been about human violence
there are so various because I have to
kind of disguise the central theme so
that I'm not bored and you're not bored
I write about human violence nuclear
weapons being the largest kind of human
violence I think that there are ways to
get past this plague that we have lived
with through all these centuries of our
experience and I write about it and will
continue to write about it
good therefore help given your immersion
and violence that gives us hope I
suppose that you have hope James you
right I know that your books actually do
have hopeful edges to them but you also
write about what what can go wrong I
guess you're somewhat the representative
of the mad scientist side of things or
things that could go and in a sort of
Frankenstein direction what about your
hopes and fears well that that's true
you know I mean in a crime novel there
will be bad people and so I mean in a
way it's unfortunate because you know I
ended up focusing a lot on kind of the
rogue scientists which is not how I
think you know most scientists are and
I'm actually very careful to balance it
out with saying you know what this
particular scientist is doing is it
would not be accepted by 99% of of the
field and and yet you know it will be I
mean it's the rogues right now as you
probably know who are trying to clone a
human you know people like za voz and
antenori and and so I mean those are
those are kind of where the stories are
I mean I do I do feel I mean with what
you just described Richard really
beautifully that this kind of you do
find a kind of spiritual side and in my
case when you find out how much you know
what a cell is capable of I mean what
what kind of you know adaptation and
kind of magic Accela can do and and and
the way scientists are unlocking that is
is just fantastic at the same time I do
feel a little I do feel some long-term
apprehension about the future of
humanity as humanity because there are a
lot of people are really interested in
transcending humanity and I'm not quite
sure you know I think what you know what
kind of drives them is an interesting
greater control greater efficiency
some sort of things that you know it's
thinking about the the passage in your
book Michael about about apples Mike
Michael Pollan about how you know
there's this fantastic diversity of
apples and and yet now what we have on
the market is been reduced to a few you
know just a few types and which in one
person describes them as having
sweetness without dimension and I kind
of worry about I mean this is very
long-term right not in our lifetimes but
about you know human beings as you know
if ways that we improve ourselves could
be moving toward you know strength
without dimension or smartness without
dimensions so I do have a mix of
apprehension in there like we're going
down the line is that I'd like to pick
up directly where you took off James
because I addressed that sense of
apprehension very much in my own
experience when I realized I would have
to get a cochlear implant I felt this
tremendous sense of fear and it's a bit
like that fear that you're talking about
that fear of changing becoming something
else something new I remember when I
took Spanish in seventh grade I thought
this had to fight it oh my god I'm going
to turn into someone who has these whole
different language structures in my
brain I'm going to have to be somebody
else that was a frightening sensation
and I still remember very vividly had
that film so I felt a similar kind of
fear I'm learning that my body would
change that my whole perceptual world
would change I think we see that fear a
lot in modern cultural representations
such as the Terminator the board words
in Captain Lee that fear that science
will change us beyond recognition the
technology will change or we think of as
our fundamentally recognizable human
cells and so I hadn't worked through
that sense of fear and what I worked
through to what this tremendous sense of
hope because what I found was that I
could work with the technology more
importantly I could work with the people
who created the technology and interact
with them to say I would like this
setting just so I'd like to have that
but that way so the technology was
designed in such a way that I have to
control over what I was becoming
I think that's an essential aspect of
cyborg technologies that the people who
use them have some agency and that is
where hope comes from that feeling that
you aren't agent in your own future that
you can reshape yourself let me just
jump in on that to say we already have
changed beyond recognition there's a
last novel of Henry James's I think he
never finished it but he was writing
about a man who walks through the
portrait of one of his ancestors back to
1820 or something like that and people
spot him immediately is strange because
he has good teeth he doesn't stink and
so forth if you think about what the
past was in fact like or read a little
bit about it just the level of odor in
the world was so appalling compared to
what we have arranged for ourselves but
think about the fact that there were
four hundred thousand breast implants
times two of course in the United States
last year I've often thought in a sort
of a crackpot futuristic way that
eventually all people who live in
prosperous cultures will look like movie
stars because that's the direction we're
all going in obviously it's gonna be a
problem but it's certainly a trend that
you see with the improvement in health
and medicine and all the marginal things
like plastic surgery we are very
different in very fundamental ways than
people used to be and has enormous
social issues too and I think about the
lifespan has been doubled in the last
centuries we don't really know what to
do with with people I mean they're you
know routinely living in other 70s and
80s and even longer now too we're
talking about extending lifespan even
further genetically two or three hundred
years ago people used to go for miles to
see someone who was old just because it
was such a rare thing to see a man who
was 90 and they were accorded great
wisdom
the artifact that there being old or a
man over six-foot yes it's another one
yes Michel yes I don't that's a hard
question because I think it's a little
too simple on this idea that you know
it's partly due to the Bush
administration but that anyone who's
critical of science now has gotten a bad
rap from the way that the Bush
administration has been attacking
science and I think we have to resist
this idea of casting all issues between
you know that it's the church versus
Galileo it's B'nai tadesse versus
enlightenment it's it's just more
complicated than that and science is not
this autonomous Hegelian force leading
to the future right now a lot of science
is controlled by power and is an
instrument of power we've seen in the
last generation biology essentially been
taken over by corporations to a very
large extent I see it on my own campus
where for a period of time one
corporation got to decide by and large
what got studied in a whole department
so the idea that science is autonomously
moving in the direction of enlightenment
I think we have to be very careful I
don't think the laymen and laywomen
quite realizes the extent to which
science is now just entwined with all
the other powers that that are working
on our lives and it will no long it will
not ever again be separated from that
right so to talk about science in these
general terms or abstract terms is I
think we make a mistake yeah no I think
I love it
a journalist going back to academia and
getting more complicated trying trying
to complicate the simple hope and fear
equation now that also is a nice segue
though into a topic that I think you
know we're all interested in this is a
journalists and people to write about
science which of course is the fact that
as we've suggested here science does not
exist in the vacuum I mean we have the
force of history we have lots of forces
at work but I think the one that
probably has a lot of our minds right
now is politics and those in power and
there's certainly the the corporate side
of things but there's also
you know political power and those in
power of the moment and you know you
can't help but pick up the paper and and
see that scientific fact is being
attacked by from different quarters
you've got the morning-after pill not
being approved by the FDA against the
advice almost unanimous of their own
Advisory Committee
you've got the stem-cell issue global
warming I mean these things are
beginning to stack up and I'm not trying
to pick on anybody here but I think
these are just somewhat objective
realities that we're dealing with and
let me open it up and jump in here let's
not do the the download of the line
anybody jump in here what you know where
where are we with with politics right
now
I mean it's Polly or maybe even ideology
is another way to describe it where
ideology is more important to those in
power at times than the sign scientific
fact where does that where does that
leave off where does that get us it is I
mean it's it's it's rife in this
government at the moment and then it's
an unprecedented really attack on
uncomfortable facts and and the more you
look at it you see and at you know the
lowest levels of the most obscure
departments where scientific conclusions
are being rewritten to serve political
ends and that's a very dangerous thing
on an issue like stem cells you you you
know that's the most kind of visible or
climate change you know on the other
hand I mean the stem cell issue in the
bush policy does raise this larger
question is well shouldn't there be some
place for political control of Science
and Technology I mean even as we object
to the way it's being waged here does it
follow from that that we should take a
completely less a fair attitude to
science and technology and I don't think
it does I think there has to be some
mechanism with these powerful
technologies that is you you say are
changing the very nature of humanity
that we as citizens somehow have to
exert some decision-making power over
how they're deployed and not be
bamboozled by the we know best we know
where we're going because I think that
could have disastrous effects so you
need to be a tension really between I
think there isn't
watchdogs in the and you know I don't
know what the answer is but again that's
what that's what I mean about the bush
war on science is giving a real bad name
to any criticism of science and I think
that that's very unfortunate
polarization other comments here yeah I
mean I think you know part of the what
what people are afraid of is is the
greater and greater commodification of
life and of our bodies and and of our
identities our identities are digital
now they can be stolen
you know our face is no longer enough
just to you know view oneself and you
know the patenting of life and life I
mean that's a that's a huge thing the
sort of private privatization of life
and I you know I have to think that part
of maybe not within the corridors of
power but for the people for whom the
some of these arguments reverberate
there's a great sense of threat and of
fear that that the the future does not
include them and that there they are
unplugged they're not going to count in
the future and they're gonna be left
behind and I don't think it's an
accident there's this huge series called
left behind in which you know which
basically says no we're not going to be
left behind you are you know there are
so many issues tangled together in this
question but just to mention one or two
I was the member for a while of a
foundation that was trying to find a
structure for determining with more
control than our federal government now
has how much money to invest in various
branches of science you know after the
end of the second world war and it was
an artifact really of the success of the
Manhattan Project the Neva Bush who had
run science for the federal government
during the war wrote a famous book
called the endless frontier and it
proposed a kind of this was a Faustian
bargain that science the best way for
the government to support science would
be to give scientists the money and let
them decide what to do with it because
it was an open-ended process and and you
couldn't guess where the discovery
would come from etc that's basically
been the model for federal spending on
science ever since and it has led to
well to take the medical example an
enormous investment in keeping pillow
people alive for one last year and and
and essentially the complete dismantling
of what used to be a wonderful public
health system it may well be that an
artifact of the biological warfare
question is the rest resuscitation of
the American Public Health System which
would be a great improvement so that's
one aspect of it but also from the point
of view of science science in nineteen
forty five physicists in nineteen forty
five became the most important asset the
nation state had and in a sense by
extension so did science science as an
institution that is to say has become an
institution at least as powerful as the
nation state system and as such I'm not
at all sure that it's controllable in
the sense that we would like it to be
except to the extent that we can broadly
say we'd like to spend more money over
here than over there I don't think
that's bad I don't think the nation's a
state system did such a damn good job of
running the world we had two huge world
wars with the development of nuclear
energy as a weapon of war we haven't had
any more World Wars it's no longer safe
to have a world war to put it
paradoxically so in that sense science
has become finally as of the middle of
the twentieth century an institution as
powerful as the most powerful
institution that human beings had
invented and this quiet little war is
going to be going on for a long time
I've no doubt who's going to win I think
science is going to win and I think that
in the long run is going to be good for
us despite the fact that as a new
political institution it is of course as
Michael rightly said plague to all the
institutions institutional corruptions
that come when institutions become
powerful and that's really I guess our
dilemma to try and see how we gonna set
the rules of the game because we forget
that what we see is the natural course
of where science is going as a result of
certain political decisions that were
made for example you talk about
intellectual property we did not I mean
this has
and in the courts but it could have been
overruled and in Congress we did not
have to say that life forms were forms
of intellectual property and had we not
made that decision you can argue whether
it's a good decision or bad it's sent
science and a bunch of biologists down a
certain path they could have gone down
another path so that this you know we
forget and we and as dick suggests we do
set the rules for what we're going to
spend money on as a society so you know
we have to remember we have the power to
make the rules in which the game is
played what about this disconnect though
between science and the public I mean
part of what we're talking about may be
policies with the current administration
that you know a lot of scientists
disagree with but it's not happening you
know by itself there there is a barrier
there there's a there's a wall on this
between the scientists the scientific
establishment and much of the rest of
the public and when you have that
situation you you get into people get
afraid I mean people are inherently
afraid of new newness anyway as Michael
pointed out but there doesn't seem to be
much of a bridge building between the
two communities it's the public's likes
the goodies that they get they like the
medicines and everything but there's not
a great deal of communication and in
fact it's sort of circles around again -
we were all writers none of us here are
scientists you know in a way where we're
the messengers and hopefully we don't
get killed but you know how do we just
and by the way anybody who has questions
we're almost to that part of the the
program here so if you want to start
standing up by the microphone go ahead
but you know how do we as communicators
as the messengers convince people I mean
every everyone here has written books
that people have have read but how do we
get that word out how do we penetrate
that barrier let me jump in on that I
want to pick up on one of Michaels
points about the contingency in science
that science is not its inevitable march
from ignorance to knowledge that the way
science develops is very contingent on
the individual decisions of individual
people for example the first commercial
cochlear implant which was developed in
Australia was developed by someone who
Lear
stealing corners and gathered money to
support his research it's absolutely
astounding Kevin started you talking
Norma's risks and encountered a bus of
opposition by his colleagues the
development of cochlear implants is by
no means inevitable is not a natural
outgrowth of the way science develops in
our society so I think that one way of
communicating breaking down that barrier
between science and the general public
is to communicate how human and
enterprise audience is and the fact that
if different people had chosen to do
different things you would have a
different science we have different
technologies different tools in
different institutions so it's very much
a matter of personal passions as well as
institutional and parents let's be sure
that we make a distinction between
science and technology you're really
talking about the development of a
technology the basic science have to do
with studying the brain with developing
electronics with developing computers so
those two things are not entirely
overlapping that's a given bother
they've been running together in the
last few years which is I think are they
overlap quite a bit especially when it's
an interesting moment when it when it
comes from scientific discovery to
application and which has happened so
fast sometimes we do confuse the two I
always think about Oppenheimer said he
said we didn't do any physics from 1939
to 1945 really high-level engineering
these weapons yeah let's open it up to
some questions here yeah and in the
close to 82 years of my survival I've
seen a tremendous amount of changes and
I like your reaction to this comment and
I'm gonna make I believe that the our
economic system our capitalist system
whatever is completely dependent on
science in order to have it go forward
at the same time our individual systems
which is human beings are completely
dependent on science of where to go
forward I mean we don't look to a shame
into what we have an illness we go to
science and I think because of these two
issues
it's inevitable science will triumph I
like your reaction anybody wanna well I
mean I agree with you and and I think
the old opposition which people still
like to quote that technology has
advanced but the human spirit hasn't
advanced and we are not keeping up with
the changes in technology really doesn't
represent the reality of the world we
live in we are keeping up its if you
think about just the development of the
internet in the last 15 years it's
extraordinary how much the world has
changed and I wouldn't be willing to bet
that at least 80% of this audiences
completely computer literate and has it
been a disadvantage yeah I suppose but
it's also been an enormous advantage in
many ways so again I say because science
is self-correcting
despite the corruption despite all these
other issues in the long run I don't see
what else can prevail it's the only
thing that gives us solid factual
evidence about the world we live in
anybody else want to comment on that get
some more question or do you have
another question
anybody else interested in walking up
and asking a question here I have a lot
of them if you don't so yes I have a
question I'm somebody who used to be a
scientist and now I'm an artist and
studying writing and one thing that I'm
finding that's it's it's a really
different mindset and sigh you know
people who are interested in science
tend to enjoy understanding systems and
all that yet you know in writing you
need to have drama you need to have
conflict and all that and a lot of
scientific stories don't seem at first
glance to a lot of people to have you
know the sort of human conflict I mean
so many do but how do you communicate
science to a public that doesn't
necessarily most people don't
necessarily have intrinsic interest in
seeing systems that way well I challenge
I think you don't call it science
frankly I mean I don't use that word and
I don't what word do you use I'm writing
about you know intoxication I'm writing
about sweetness I'm writing about the
brain I'm writing about our lives I use
science as a tool to understand not the
only tool I don't think it I don't think
it's the it's you know the last word on
everything by any means I mean I think
things get interesting when you bring
several different lenses to the same
subject now I mean I don't write about
science per se I'm not a beat science
writer and and and they and there are
certainly challenges but you know
science is as Dick said it's about
nature that's what I see my subject is
is nature our nature and the nature of
the natural world and science is one of
the the tools we have for understanding
that and and people are endlessly
fascinated in themselves and how their
minds work and subjects like forgetting
and what they should be eating and what
food does to you and and all these kind
of things and you can use science and
and and talk all about that but I never
say it's science there's sort of a
buzzkill about that word that's people
turn off I mean I think that's I know as
a writer trying to sell science science
stories I've always feeling funny as an
English major you know being a science
writer yeah no well no no no I'm just
being termed that because you're really
writing about the things like brain
implants and cloning and face
transplants and oh my god those things
are interesting but if you yeah but I
think the point even within within a
piece of writing is ultimately what I
think I'm doing is writing narrative
with all the meanings of that word I
discovered for example in the making of
the atomic bomb and trying to decide how
to explain scientific experiments the
workbench type experiments that they
were little narratives in them in
themselves and if I walk through them in
that way Ernest Rutherford put a brass
box on the table and it had two pet
[ __ ] on each end and he put a piece of
radium inside etc was perfectly clear to
me what he was doing and what the
outcome meant and I hope it was to the
reader but it was by breaking down the
experiment into its original series of
events
and then reflecting on them that I think
I got I understood it myself and help
the reader understand it narrative is
surely stories are surely the basic
mnemonic device of our species so to the
extent that you can turn what you're
working on into a series of narratives
linked narratives you're home free my
tactic is to pretty much trick people by
having them think they're reading a
detective story and the you know and the
story has to be primary you know and
novels like mine and hard work for me is
figuring out how to in entwine the
science with with the crime and with the
story so that they're always very
closely integrated but I mean I have to
say and in reading all four of these
guys books I mean you're the narrative
your narrative artist is really I mean
you know it's at the best novelistic
level that yeah I mean all four of your
books or I mean I'm just really
impressed I mean they read like great
novels yeah there's a mini trend in
science finding and science finders
writing about their own experiences
Steven Jonathan's book mine wide open
for example it's about him putting
himself through a series of medical
tests in the quest to understand how his
own brain works and there's been a
number of books and then being lately
have another question there I have a
relatively directed question for Michael
so which Michael Michael me Morris Club
thank you thank you I'm so it's actually
a two-part question the first part is um
can you adjust your device so that you
can actually hear better than anybody in
the room and then do is anybody in the
panel find an important distinction
between or I find a gap exists between
the idea that it's okay to sort of bring
somebody who can't hear as well as
everybody in the room up to that level
but no further in that I would find it
interesting to hear your remarks is it
okay for you to turn your hearing all
the way up so that you can hear me
across the street you know
okay steve austin the bionic man i'm
fully but and i think i think we find it
socially okay to bring you to the median
tom but we find it quite alarming to
bring you anybody further and i'd like
to hear whether or not any of you
question things have an important
distinction between replacement
technologies and enhancement
technologies so what I have as a
cochlear implant is a replacement
technology it restores to some extent
the hearing that I lost but if by no
means gives me a bionic hearing in the
sense of the bionic moment I could not
hear you you know through walls for
example that would be nice but I don't
have that particular property now when I
was researching how a normally
functioning ear works I was overwhelmed
by how extraordinary and mechanism it is
and I think it's going to be a long time
before we can equal or better that kind
of sophistication with the big clumsy
macroscopic machines that we've built
now so I think that enhancement
technologies are the kind of talking
about are still a ways off now of course
be enhance our bodies with all sorts of
external technologies cell phones just
for example allow you to hear somebody
across the continent but I don't think
that's what you're talking about when
you talk about enhancement you're
talking about fundamentally changing the
human body so that it's better faster
stronger more durable you know I don't
like to say that will never happen
because predictions like that are
routinely proven wrong I will say
however that you know knowing what I've
learned about how incredible the human
body is I think it's going to be a long
time before enhancement technologies
become commercially available and
normalized
I mean steroid use is a perfect example
of enhancement we take athletes much
further than the ordinary human being is
that would be allowed to when you find
that quite alarming but yet but if you
take steroids for example and drop it
down to a level of replacement then you
have hormone replacement therapy for men
and for women
which has its problems but it is a very
effective way of retarding aging
perhaps improving health well it's also
the issue of abuse and anytime you have
a technology or a science that's applied
there's a opportunity for abuse so I'm
going back to the fire analogy you know
we put those people in jail and that's
one way to control it I do need to pause
here for a second if you don't mind and
say the following
for the broadcast audience this is the
Commonwealth club's inform program with
lick quick and tonight we're talking
with science writers about the
intriguing discoveries that inspire
their work I'm David Ewing Duncan
journalist and author and I'm here with
Richard Rhodes Pulitzer Prize winning
author James Calder mastermind of the
bill Damon's series michael chorost
author of rebuilt how becoming part
computer made me more human and michael
paalan author of the botany of desire
and other books and let's continue on to
the questions so my question is
essentially does science work we have
the 20th century which was the
information age and the ascendancy of
science we sent someone to the moon but
I think the 20th century will also be
remembered as the genocide all century
we had the Holocaust and we had Rwanda
and we had Sudan and we and Kosovo so
you have this wonderful niels bohr
quote and you have this wonderful
rationality but you know does this are
we still missing something is this just
a cult rationality you know excuse me
what I think is very interesting about
the first half of the 20th century was
the question of why war escalated in in
violence the way it did if you graph the
number of man-made deaths in the first
half of the 20th century it's not an
exponential growth it goes up and down
but you find it in 1916 the number of
people killed that year in war was
around 8 million and then in the 1930s
with Stalin's terror famine and and and
his Great Terror
it was up around that as well but by the
height of the Second World War
1943 1944 15 million people pretty
so there was a gradual but very visible
and regular escalation I think you have
to explain that by saying that the
nation-state in the twentieth century
discovered that it could use technology
to aggrandize its power the technologies
that first were quite simple they were
machine guns
poison gas issues like that the bomber
and then of course ultimately the
development of nuclear weapons but that
turned out to be an end they turned out
to be so destructive that they could not
be used and instead of becoming
something that caused more deaths in the
years afterward the chart drops down
very vividly and and directly and
steeply in 1945 and 1946 and stays at a
very low level for the rest of the 20th
century so evidently that's why I said I
think in 1945 science suddenly emerged
as the most powerful human institution
ever devised it made it was so powerful
that the nation-state basically could no
longer use the weapons that it in this
sort of bizarre process continued to
accumulate you have to think about the
fact that we had 50,000 nuclear weapons
in the Soviets had 75,000 nuclear
weapons and no one in their right minds
ever thought of using them except as a
bluff and as a way of looking tough and
as the way that we hope to protecting
ourselves from the other side so I think
that it's not I mean I don't think
Boersma Marquez is simple-minded around
or surprisingly optimistic all of the
struggles that we're talking about are
encapsulated into the statement the
gradual removal of prejudices whether
you want to call them prejudices or not
they're human beliefs that we've built
whole institutions around so it's a very
profound remark as boards often were and
not at all necessarily an optimistic one
but I hope realistic although some of
the new Sciences and Technology
especially bio science it can't be
controlled by an entity like like the
the nation-state and you've got you know
after 9/11 the 21st century may end up
being having a very different use of
these technologies bioterrorism biology
has as much potential for destruction as
physics did in the last century
absolutely a lot easier to do as well
and can be done in very small labs by
very few people that's going to be the
challenge yeah next question it's been
suggested tonight several times that
science is our salvation or what will
save us and I'd like to suggest that we
are all here at a lit quake you are all
science writers not scientists and that
science isn't nearly as effective in the
lab as it is when it comes out in a
narrative or in a communication and it
perhaps it's actually communication and
narrative and literature that will save
us I like that given there no scientists
on the panels to defend that thank you
just brief response I would say that
it's really the ability to create
meaningful narratives of experience that
humanizes and I think that's one of the
reasons that technology and science
often go awry when they use without
regard for where they fit into an
overall story of human development so I
think that your point is very much one
telling you because the question really
ultimately is save us for what at the
end of one of yo Wilson's books he says
you know if in 200 years we've squared
the circle solve the resources problem
solve the population problem etc we're
all going to wake up one day and
discover that we have no more purpose in
the world if you believe the scientific
story then the reproduction of our kind
and at that point it's going to be a
major spiritual crisis for the whole
species well what do we do now and we
become like like the Apple and the tulip
again my question is for mr. Rhodes you
made a very a statement that I found
quite intriguing that we dismantled a
very good health system or something to
that effect could you expand on that the
public health system was really
developed after the Second World War in
the United States in the context of the
war on malaria but we at that point had
a system where kids got their
vaccinations we're epidemiologists kept
track of the emergence of a new cluster
of diseases or illnesses
and there was a system of response built
around the Public Health Service this
all slowly fell apart after I think the
eradication of smallpox and the
eradication certainly Apolo in the
Western Hemisphere it's only with the
re-emergence of concern about biological
warfare that it's become evident that
the best system for dealing with
biological warfare like any other
biological warfare I mean natural
biological warfare diseases is the
public health system and I gathered that
there's now some effort to put it back
together by the way by the public health
system the the respondent part of of the
government that responds the public
health crisis well it's more than that
but you know the medical delivery system
which also has its its problems but in
fact we are I mean very curiously seeing
the Bush administration jumping into the
idea of a pandemic yeah in the wake of
Katrina you know many people many of my
colleagues write about this have been
talking about this for many many years
and it's a sudden awakening among the
administration that this is out there
and we just thing to see what the
follow-through has on it because it's an
enormous enormous task to prepare
ourselves for a pandemic that I just
took yesterday I was at a meeting
sitting next to one of the experts of
infectious disease in the entire world
Barry bloom from Harvard and he he said
it will happen there is no question we
will have another outbreak like in 1918
well I just took the president saying
we're going to do something about it
isn't the kiss of death he'll pour
hopefully some money into it but anyway
yes next question I want to revisit the
question as to which factors may lead
science to bring us into human progress
humanity progress in humanity or towards
the demise of humanity and if we take
the view that science inevitably will
lead us towards more powerful technology
and more potential
for either of those points what factors
do you see as being important or perhaps
critical and in which way that goes many
want to jump into that well you know I
think knowing when not to use certain
technologies or Sciences that the
nuclear weapons are a great example and
I think that may come up in a more
personal way in the future for parents
of when not to use you know genetic
enhancements that or when not to you
know live for 300 years especially if
this kind of potential on a way that you
describe but you know may be a result
you know 100 years of boredom so that's
I mean that's a you know and that has to
do with with knowing ourselves a certain
you know wisdom as opposed to knowledge
this is partly the upsurge of religious
fundament of the country it's a it's a
manifestation of what does it mean to be
human and you know I I spend a fair
amount of time talking to people at
different points of view and there is a
you know humanist intellectual argument
that you don't want to go too far and
what is human and in a sort of bizarre
partisan way we're actually having a
kind of chaotic debate about that it'd
be nice if it was a little more
copacetic and organized but we are
reaching at least in my view writing it
I write about genetics and we're in a
critical moment right now when a lot of
these these discoveries in science are
about to become technologies and about
to go into use and you know what I think
we will be asking this question more and
more what does it mean to be human I
mean Michael I think is still human but
when I talked to him he appears to me
but you know what what happens when you
know we're all filled with devices like
that and you do have the option of
turning it up and hearing somebody you
know the other end of Market Street here
in San Francisco you know these are
questions that are here and now and we
need to be talking about them and there
is also the question - of who you know
who will have the resources to command
these technologies - obviously very big
question you know I mean the rich have
always gotten the good stuff first and
this was true you know the car and and
all sorts of technologies and it's gonna
have
with these these technologies but there
is a you know there's tremendous social
cost if technology tends to increase the
inequality of society which I mean that
is definitely a tendency and very hard
to arrest but this idea of absorb during
new technologies I think is a very
important one and you know right now
there's a there's actually a remarkable
consensus around the idea that we
shouldn't do reproductive cloning I mean
you know across I think across the board
in societies all over the all over the
world I'm curious to see whether it'll
hold or we'll just kind of get
comfortable with that idea and then it
will happen because a few you know rich
people will decide they want to do it
but but it seems to me we do have some
moral compass about these things and
that as of now and and my guess is for a
long time that that's that's a creepy
idea that people aren't actually people
don't want to go there I mean that is
it's a freakish thing to want to
reproduce yourself exactly and then
variety and what you were talking about
this idea of the unexpected not wanting
to control everything how boring control
is Michael I might need to jump in here
and we'll have that as the last word and
the people who have questions we will
the panels will be available afterwards
and I want to give a big hand to our
panelists if you'll join me
[Applause]
now this meeting of in forum in a
Commonwealth Club is adjourned this
panel was hosted by the Commonwealth
Club of California for more information
about the club or its upcoming events
visit common